hey I'm Kristian harloff and I'm Tiffany
Smith and our guest for today is I can't
do it so thank you so much Justine for
hanging out with us and completing our
super pump to have you and I know you're
crazy busy
you just had a book come out called
hydrastine in June yeah we're just in
The Wedding ringer with Kevin Hart what
are you not I also just got a puppy so
my life has just completely changed DJ
he is DJ DJ Minnie matte it always
fascinates me with celebrities of what
genre of movie they like do you have a
particular genre that you respond to
more than others I probably comedy
movies it's like if you don't like a
funny movie there's definitely something
wrong with you what's the last one that
you watch that you embarrass yourself
laughing I think I watched part of a
notebook Nicholas Sparks movie that
isn't Justin we are very good at
embarrassing ourselves every weekend on
this show Christian mostly me basically
what we do is we put our butts on the
line every week with our weekly rager
last week it was all about straight out
of Compton we had a movie threesome and
I believe you wagered 32 million you age
of 26 for the actual estimated value was
sixty point two million which means it's
time for you to have the loser should
Chris day says hashtag loser should
throw water balloons at the loser face
chris is classic I get it that I'm the
loser face of this episode but I mean we
can't get the set wet so Oh contraire
loser face well Tiffany you can't
complain anymore we are now outside in
three two
like ten balloons loser-face you did a
great job and now we have to go back to
this too
you know we both were agreements that
trail that Compton will probably number
one again because of that we're gonna
bet on what we think sinister to will do
I'm gonna say sinister to make sixteen
point five million this room colors of
the box office with fourteen months
that's a good bet Justine how about you
I'm not betting anything our first smart
person make sure that you send in those
hashtag loser shoulds in the comments
below on YouTube on Twitter on Facebook
think I'm gonna submit one ha ha ha a
massive tech junkie along with loving
films what is some of the new technology
that's really helped you feel like
there's a new computer that comes out
pretty much every well actually I feel
like every day there's something new
it's really amazing to the feed the
price on these things have come down to
so it's accessible to everybody all you
guys have a camera camera camera there's
like can we make it a little bit bigger
look that is CGI
Justin our crappy CGI dog with standing
there has been a lot of movie effects
over the years maybe they haven't aged
so well but at the time they were
groundbreaking let's start with Air
Force one back in 1997 huge hit this is
still holding up all right ok see it's
amazing though but back from when this
movie came out look that's so amazing
how quickly technology changes now that
there's like children they're doing
another one that had some pretty awesome
visual effects for the time was The
Mummy Returns in 2001 without effects
like this you don't get a golem you
don't get these any circus later on yeah
you don't see and that looks not great
but this was the beginning of it this
was gonna be gayness through the start
of it that they could do stuff like this
this is where they started to learn so
long you're just looking in his face I'm
like I love this one this one to me is
one of my favorites of all time
Jurassic Park 1993 one of the best
visual masterpieces ever I definitely
think it's really great the dinosaurs
look awesome I think the Lord of the
Rings films and what what a workshop did
when you see the two towers and you get
to see Gollum and you get to see what
Andy Serkis could do with that character
that changed the game for sure which one
out of the two you guys do you think
knows the most about special effects me
I like it I like the competitiveness
that to me sounds a lot like
it is movie Tac Toe it's gonna be all
about special effects I'm gonna ask a
couple questions and first person to get
it right you're gonna stick one of your
creepy faces on to the tic-tac-toe board
if you get it wrong your opponent gets
to put their previous on the board yeah
I need to play tic-tac-toe with my face
what does ILM stand for industrial light
magic I thought you were doing multiple
choice what percentage of James
Cameron's Avatar was photorealist at a
60% be 100% C 10% 10 you get the boy
Justino really someone's playing
favorite you said 50 the first wireframe
computer graphics were featured in what
movie Hey Tron be alien see Star Wars
Tron
No first to accomplish the extensive 3d
animated scenes in the first Tron movie
how much memory did the computer back
then have a one gigabyte be 500
megabytes see all right it was two
minutes okay which completely CG Lord of
the Rings character was a hailed
state-of-the-art golem thank you dude I
didn't say abs a the first motion
capture feature film was eight the Bolar
compress be the molar empress the ball
see I'm very disappointed with people
it looks like no one's going to win this
game I can win you're not going to get
next to right you're right but you how
many minutes of CG dinosaurs are there
in Jurassic Park a four be 15 see none
those are all real bones park so no one
wins the audience doesn't win no one
wins make sure you check her out on
social media at iJustine and pick up her
book hydrastine at iJustine book calm
and let us know in the comments below
there's any other guest that you want to
have come on movie threesome with us why
don't you guys also make sure that you
subscribe to this YouTube channel make
sure you also download the Fandango
movie clips app on your smartphone and
join us next week on Louie baby Steve
Steve Steve